you have food trucks in your
neighborhood I do we have lots of them
and I like them they provide good
different foods at good prices
Laura Peck Eric drives a food truck in
Chicago
she sells cupcakes and the truck let her
open a business without having to hire a
staff and rent a whole building I was
able to rent a kitchen space instead of
renting a whole brick and mortar and
managing a team of people it was just me
and one baker at the time and everything
kind of was under my control to kind of
get my feet wet in the in the business
joven oneís a food truck entrepreneur in
Baltimore
he sells pizza not just any pizza
delicious pizza where'd you get the idea
to open this food truck I was looking
around for some jobs and could not find
anything it's kind of a new idea it
really started taking off right around
the recession you know 2008 timeframe a
lot of restaurant entrepreneurs the
capital they had was not enough to
actually go out and start a restaurant
on their own banks weren't willing to
give loans so the food truck phenomenon
really took off food trucks are just a
way for people to enter dick carpenter
of the Institute for justice studied
food trucks and concluded it they're an
important part of the economy because
they provide a first rung for people
starting out the costs are often much
less for a food truck so it's a way for
them to get into business and then grow
that business into something bigger but
new rules now make that tougher some
cities restrict food truck sales to two
hours others tell food trucks you may
not park near an established restaurant
it became ever more difficult to find
parking locations when we went to the
city to try to sell our cupcakes I would
have customers calling me trying to find
us and I was like I'm trying I'm trying
to find a parking spot I'll post as soon
as I as I land every moment that we're
driving around and that parked in the
location with our window open and that
we couldn't sell
parkings limits it because politicians
want to protect existing restaurants and
you can't be 300 feet next to a
restaurant that offers the same product
well their pizzeria is all over
Baltimore
so that means Joey is severely
restricted and where you can go there
paying taxes they had they use
brick-and-mortar Baltimore's just trying
to keep things fair well it's funny you
say that John because I also invested in
my business and I pay taxes as well so
you can still run your business you just
have to stay away from those restaurants
there's almost no place left for me to
operate but we must protect existing
restaurants says Chicago alderman Tom
Tunney I'm going to be prejudicial
towards those kind of businesses because
that keeps my neighborhood a
brick-and-mortar is a much more stable
enterprise this is a prime example of
protectionism wait who are these kids
talking about protectionism I'm even and
then Emily together were the Tuttle
twins more on the Tuttle twins and in
another video but they rightly asked why
would god form in favor of business over
another that's a good question
oftentimes it's because one side lobbied
for regulations sometimes that side also
donated money to a politician's campaign
man the government can be so shady
yes it can be and by the way Tony the
politician who's in charge of limiting
food truck parking in this district just
happens to own some brick-and-mortar
restaurants at least he discloses that
for obvious transparency reasons I'm a
restaurant operator in the city of
Chicago for almost 40 years they want to
keep competitors as far away as possible
the guy who opened the restaurant and
had to pay real estate taxes and pay for
his building isn't he getting ripped off
by these new guys that assumes that the
food truck operator doesn't pay expenses
of the same type in fact food truck
operators pay taxes they pay rents and
through their rents they pay property
taxes
Laura and Joey now are fighting the
regulations in court they argue it's
unconstitutional to favor one industry
at the expense of another to try to push
us back and down and prevent us from
doing business is unfair this case with
Laura five years and going the
Restaurant Association has so much
influence over those who are elected
officials that gives existing
restaurants the power to stop newcomers
by imposing lots of rules this is true
of all bon liqueurs yes it is like
closing a lane on the highway bottleneck
er stop all sorts of progress
cosmetologist take jobs from hair
braiders optometrist band computer eye
tests union bus companies ban these
minivans florists say you may not do
flower arrangements without a license
these bottlenecks say they're protecting
us but mostly they collude with
government to protect themselves in this
case taking away our choices one meal at
a time
you